so you have a very interesting former
life as a paralegal leave you got an MBA
you were working at AIG before and she
was no longer tell us about that world
how you felt every day getting up going
to that type of an environment and did
you let them know that you'd been in
bands prior to that in your site because
that's habit
no that wasn't taboo exactly but it
definitely was there of course it's an
expectation when you're working on Wall
Street that nothing is going to
interfere with your professional
dedication but in any corporate job or
business job or a professional job that
is the expectation and it should be one
thing I don't know I might be getting
off topic a little bit but I know one
thing that sort of I think led me to
where I am right now was I did always
feel this pressure from my family who I
eventually worked for that I needed to
work work hard I needed to prove myself
in the professional world I just I felt
like there was this you're lazy or maybe
it was a little bit sexist
you know women aren't worth it worth
working they should they should spend
money or be maids or be wives and spend
money on credit cards so I always felt
like I needed to prove that wrong so I
would challenge myself I I went you know
to Russia for a year in college to learn
a foreign language then I I went
straight to to Wall Street and worked at
the you know very strict machine of AIG
that you know is now pretty famous in
the world after that I went I got my
pilot certificate my commercial pilot
certificate and my flight instructor
certificate all these things that are
just really really hard and like when
were like the men in my family because
it was sort of a male
feeling ever gonna say ok Rebecca yeah
you're smart you work hard you know you
deserve some credit and finally and then
I went and I went to Carnegie Mellon and
did a really quantitative MBA program
finally I am I went and began working
for my family and for my grandpa who was
the patriarch and he died and my uncle
took over and it was just a ticking time
bomb he he finally you know he was very
much rooted izing me and he finally
fired me and that was it that was the
breaking point that was when I was like
this other trade that I've always
dabbled in always moonlighted playing in
rock bands with my female friends always
like loved writing songs spent time
recording them that was it that was when
I was just gonna say I don't care what
anybody thinks anymore or what they I'm
never gonna please anyone and and that
was the turning point when we really
really went for it with the band and I
was lucky to have my outrageous and
risk-averse female friends to go along
with it
you